first of all let me say I regret deeply
the need to drive efficiency very hard
and that it will have an impact on jobs
in centrica and that we announced today
as you say another 4,000 jobs the driver
for this efficiency program are three
things really the first is actually what
our customers want and that our
customers are asking to go more digital
the the channels in which we reach
customers are therefore changing the
costs of those channels tend to be lower
and unfortunately they use fewer people
the second big driver is about
competitive pressure where we've got to
keep driving to be the most efficient
price setter that we can consistent with
the level of service we want to give and
the third driver is this impending price
cap so I'm afraid there is a linkage
between this price cap and the need to
drive efficiency and these job losses
but you've been quite clear there these
measures have been forced on you partly
because of the government's price cap
why is that
well these measures have been have been
forced on us in part by but not only by
the impending price cap why is that
because if our prices are going to be
capped then we clearly need to drive
costs as hard as we can the government
indeed say that's one of their stated
outcomes they want to achieve through
this price cap we believe that the
analysis is fundamentally flawed in the
supporting this price cap but more
worryingly we actually think a price
caps can be bad for customers if you
look at the one that's been implemented
already in the prepayment market we've
ended up with most prices within ten
pounds of each other it's a little bit
like university tuition fees everyone
now is charging the same as the cap it's
reducing competition and we think it's
actually going to be bad so there's
quite a lot going on in the market right
now and power and SSE merging their
household supply businesses she'll have
just come into the market via its
purchase of first utility how
do you think the competitive landscape
is gonna get for you well look first of
all this market is extremely competitive
already there are 67 suppliers so adding
one or two or if you like adding one in
the form of shell and taking one away
through the proposed consolidation of
two of our competitors means it'll stay
about the same number competitions a
good thing it's good for customers we
shouldn't fear it it makes us sharper
now there's been a lot of response to
the statement today from the unions from
the Labour Party the Labour Party again
talking about nationalization of assets
how concerned are you about that look I
realize that people get very concerned
when job losses are announced and and
clearly with our colleagues in the
unions I mean we've already been working
with them we we are actually aligned on
some aspects of of energy policy with
the unions but clearly they're going to
be standing up for their members here
this is the beginning of a long
conversation with them it's not even
clear yet how many of the job losses
will necessarily be an individual union
represented group so I think it's
probably a little bit premature but I
respect their position as far as the
Labour Party's concerned I believe that
we need to engage with them as we do all
parties we always do and we are and
they're entitled to their their views we
believe that competitive markets are the
way to go in energy and I will be
engaging with Rebecca long Bailey and
the other colleagues in the Labour Party
as we walk forward do you think the
share price performance over the last 12
months reflects concerns over
nationalization
I think the share price performance over
the last 12 months clearly reflects much
more than our cash flow and performance
because although you know people can
argue about them we did meet our
published 2017 targets we did have a
performance issue but not known until
the fourth quarter and most of the
decline
share price was over the first three
quarters of the year that means that
most of it was caused by things outside
our control I have to believe that there
is a lot of political uncertainty in the
share price that's why we addressed
today how we were going to deal with
primarily the price cap issue and as we
walk forward through the rest of this
year I expect that a lot of that
uncertainty will lift we are focusing on
performance and discipline and
delivering for our customers great to
talk to you thanks your time thank you
very much and thank you